etonnant non les gros gros les crocro
les chroniques de la haine ordinaire
cette affaire et si tu avances qui cette
affaire
sharansky qui a fait pleurer dans les
chaumières et sangloter dans les
kibboutz et bien émouvante et puis
n'avons nous pas lieu d'être fiers nous
autres français de vivre en ce pays la
france la france terre d'asile sans
goulag où les juifs pour toujours un ami
publicitaires chez qui je prenais impôts
servent à 3 po bonjour les dégâts
s'étonnait que les soviétiques eu si
facilement laissé filer ce martyr vivant
de l'hydre totalitaire contre une
poignée de sous gestion en réalité plus
grillé que le feu rouge de la place
saint-michel les samedis soir de cuite à
la place de gorbatchev me disait cet ami
je n'aurais pas échangé sharansky contre
de barils une lessive ordinaire on voit
par là combien les gens de la publicité
on moralement et intellectuellement
évolué depuis l'ère obscurantistes
débats dimanche de la brillantine
cadeaux ricin et de la dauphine renault
dont d'intrépides pionnier de la réclame
sonore chantait ainsi les louanges sur
radio abidjan au milieu des années 50
faites attention je vais chanter mais
pas longtemps
vous n'aurez pas longtemps je vous
demande de rester les coudes ce n'est
qu'un mauvais moment à passer
le journal de patrice bertin et juste
après alors pour pouf
je vous épargne l'accent ivoiriens y'a
pas de raison que je prenne l'accent il
varie ivoiriens je veux dire quand il
chantait la marseillaise rouge elle ne
prenait pas l'accent 2001 alors on va
l'écouter la pub de la dauphine radio
abidjan pour promener yao koffi et puis
kouadio j'ai acheté une drôle de petite
auto vous promenez yao confié puis
kouadio j'ai acheté une auto c'est une
nouveau lot
[Applaudissements]
merci je pense que cela méritait une
brève ovation à vrai dire la plus grande
victime de la publicité contemporaine
sur elle-même et sur l'image ringarde au
mercantile qui lui collait au spot ou au
placard c'est selon le support ça plus
génial et ça plus subtile idées à la pub
c'est d'avoir réussi en quelques années
à se hisser dans l'opinion au rang d'un
art à part entière au rang d'un art
nouveau le huitième ou neuvième suivant
que vous mettiez ou non le cul dans le
temps désormais en débat dans les salons
du dernier clip pense à nouilles les
journaux bon chic bonne gauche analyse
minutieusement à longueur de colonnes
les allégories parra phrénique sous
jacente dans le message canigou on
s'entre décerne des trophées comme à
cannes et on ne dit plus qu on fait de
la pub on fait de la communication
d'ailleurs si jamais vous voyez le mot
publicité dans le nom d'une agence de
publicité
je vous ai change sakharov contre deux
mistral gagnant naguère méprisé par
l'élite la publicité à force de s'auto
convaincre qu'elle avait du génie a fini
par en persuader les autres y compris
mon beau frère christian daguerre encore
publiphobe au point qu'il allait en
lambeaux à force d'avoir tenté en vain
de découdre les crocodiles sur ses polos
pour ne pas avoir à participer au nom de
monsieur lacoste sur les courts de
tennis ou d'ailleurs son maintien
crêpier de la raquette servait plus les
intérêts de monsieur tefal que ceux de
ce grand joueur de ping pong sur gaza
pour être franc il faut reconnaître que
la pub ne les a pas volés finalement ses
lettres de noblesse si l'on veut bien
accepter les crapuleries près
paléolithique de certains cuistre
lessiviers évidemment oui seuls quelques
traits pas nation bâclé à la
tronçonneuse malpropre ou l' intrusion
inopinée d'un entrepôt pittet quai d'une
truie gonflables dans leur arbre
généalogique peuvent expliquer les
mystérieux mobile qui poussent parfois
des êtres humains
extérieurement normaux a tenté de faire
vendre des poudre à laver en montrant la
femme comme une soeur inférieure de la
guenon
c'est même un handicapé moteur ça tourne
sitôt fini de filmer plein pot déconne
heureuse de frotter la merde se
regroupent dans des tavernes huppé ou
frétillant dans leurs blousons courrèges
le chivas à la main et la banane dans
l'oreille
il distribue sans rire des blâmes et des
satisfecit aux derniers films de kubrick
ou d'ettore scola
mais il y a aussi les franchet good
chico vialas chatiliez ou beineix et
chabrol lassé d'un long métrage et plein
d'autres encore mais je connais mieux
les crus du médoc qui nous font chavirer
l'oeil de folimage éclaboussante qui
sont vraiment la beauté pure de cette
morne fin de siècle dont on ne voit
jamais la fin parce que tout le monde se
dégonfle d'appuyer sur le bouton pour
déclencher la troisième je le répète et
je pèse mes mots ce que font ces gens
ces publicitaires là c'est beau je vous
faire une confidence j'ai réussi à me
procurer la cassette de la superbe
publicité citroën
les chevrons sauvages de richard annales
et bien quand je me sent déprimé je me
la projette sur le combiné télé vidéo
que j'ai fait installer dans ma voiture
une ford ont fait pas plus confortable
quant au mois de mars
je le dis sans aucune arrière pensée
politique ça m'étonnerait que possible
[Applaudissements]
etonnant non
[Musique]